[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOLENE TEO: Hi,
everyone, I'm Jolene Teo.
JEEVANA HEGDE: And
I'm Jeevana Hegde.
JOLENE TEO: And we're
both customer engineers
at Google Cloud.
JEEVANA HEGDE: And we're
excited to have you
back at our technical
guide for startups
where we are creating
a series of videos
for technical enablement
to start, build, and grow
your businesses successfully
and sustainably on Google Cloud.
JOLENE TEO: In our
previous video,
we spoke about cost
optimization and billing.
And moving on to the final
episode of the start series
today, we'll be
sharing with you more
about support packages and
customer care at Google Cloud.
JEEVANA HEGDE: In
this video, we're
going to do an overview of
customer care portfolio,
understand what the scope
of Google Cloud support is
and the different
support options
offered to you by Google Cloud.
We will also do a demo on
how to purchase support
and how to create
a support case.
We will then be wrapping
up our start series
and look at what we have
next for you in store.
So without any further
ado, let's get started.
JOLENE TEO: Cloud support
is definitely crucial,
as it provides you
with the support
that you may need across
many aspects of your startup
journey, such as,
firstly, product usage
questions and
technical help, feature
requests, unexpected
product behavior,
and last but not least, billing
and administration questions.
And we want to be
able to give you
the incredible experience
and comprehensive support
as you build on Google Cloud.
JEEVANA HEGDE: To meet
the needs of customers
and deliver a better
experience, Google Cloud
has re-envisioned our
customer care portfolio.
The vision places customers at
the center of the model, so you
don't have to shuffle between
different support teams
or systems; a flexible
service, so you
can choose the
right offering that
is perfect for your
business needs;
and an ongoing partnership,
so your people can get answers
to all their questions.
JOLENE TEO: Simplify and
streamline your support
experience with the
Google Cloud customer care
portfolio, which has a
scalable set of offerings
built around your needs.
Choose from the core offerings
of basic, standard, enhanced,
and premium.
And there are also
additional value
added services available
for enhanced and premium.
And we'll be going through
each offering in detail.
JEEVANA HEGDE:
Starting with basic.
This is the support tier you
will receive when you sign up
on Google Cloud.
You can avail this offering
at no cost via chat, phone,
or cases, but only for
billing-related issues.
Additionally, please check the
link in the description box
below to get the pricing
details for the other offerings.
JOLENE TEO: Next we
have standard support,
a simple and flexible
way to ensure
that your workloads are running
smoothly on Google Cloud.
Standard support is a
paid support offering
highly recommend for small
and medium enterprises looking
to begin their journey
on Google Cloud.
This offering
helps you to easily
build, troubleshoot, and test.
Standard enables you to
receive technical help
from Google experts
through creating cases
with a four-hour
response time for cases
with high impact and a
overall 8/5 availability.
JEEVANA HEGDE: Next up,
we have enhanced support,
which delivers rapid response
times and additional services
to boost your
productivity and help
you run the Cloud efficiently.
There is both case and phone
support for technical issues
with a one-hour response time.
There is 24/5
availability overall
and 24/7 for critical issues.
You can also have add-ons
or value add services
like we mentioned earlier,
like technical account advisor
service and event management.
JOLENE TEO: And the final
offering is premium support.
Premium support is the highest
value support offering,
supplying you with incredibly
fast response times.
There are many
features that come
with having premium
support, some of which
include having a named
technical account manager,
having new product
previews, operational health
reviews, training resources,
as well as an event management
service.
There is also case and phone
support for technical issues,
as well as third-party
technology support.
There is also a
15-minute response time
for critical impact cases,
as well as 24/7 support
for critical impact issues.
JEEVANA HEGDE: Moving on
to a demonstration, let's
go over how to purchase support
within your Google Cloud
Console.
Go to your Google Cloud Console,
and you can see your dashboard.
Now, move to the Navigation
menu, hover over Support,
and click on Overview.
Here is the overview dashboard
for your Support page.
Go to the Support
Information card,
and select view
support offerings.
Under Standard Support, for
example, click on Buy Now.
In the dropdown list, select
the Google Cloud organization
resource for the offering.
And then click on Continue.
In the dropdown list here,
select the Cloud billing
account for the standard
support base fee.
Read and agree to
the terms of service,
and then click on
Complete Purchase.
And that's it.
You have yourself your
standard support tier.
It works very similarly
for enhanced, as well as
premium support.
JOLENE TEO: Next, moving
on to the second demo,
I'll be showing you how
you can create a support
case in your console.
First, go to your console and
navigate to the Support page
as a support user.
As you can see in
the console, you
can create cases
through various channels
depending on your
support package.
In the Cases tab, if you have
previously created any cases,
you should be able to see
a list of them over here.
And from here, to
create a new case,
simply click on Create Case.
And following that,
all you need to do
is to complete the
required fields.
First, you need to
give your case a title.
And following that, give it a
priority ranging from P1 to P4,
with P1 being the most critical.
Thirdly, all you need to do is
to select a category, as well
as a component.
And last, but not least,
all you have to do
is to fill out the description.
As you can see, after
selecting the category, as well
as the component, a
description template
has been created for you.
And you simply need to
add in that information.
At the same time, on the
right-hand side of the screen,
you can see the help
assistant dynamically
providing some useful articles
which are relevant to your case
and could be helpful to explore.
And finally, in
the last step, you
can click Submit
to submit the case.
In this demo, I'm
not going to do so,
but you can when creating
a new support case.
After you submit
the case, you will
be redirected to the case
page where you can easily
make any form of edits
to the attributes,
add on any further comments,
as well as upload attachments
to the case.
And that concludes our
overview on support packages.
Do check out the links in
the description box below
to find out more about
customer care and support
at Google Cloud.
JEEVANA HEGDE: We're so happy
to be successfully concluding
our first segment of the
startup journey, which
was the start series.
Let's do a recap of our journey.
We kicked off the series
with the launch video
where we did an
overview of the series.
We then learned how to get
started on Google Cloud,
with an introduction to the
resource hierarchy, Cloud IaaS,
and lots of demonstrations.
Then you learned how you
can deploy your applications
with Cloud Run for
application development.
JOLENE TEO: You also saw how
to configure Google Kubernetes
Engine, how you could build and
leverage Google Compute Engine,
as well as manage your
networking configurations.
JEEVANA HEGDE: We then did
the database configurations
for the same
application, so you know
how the flow for a
single application works.
We learned how Firebase can
be used to build, improve,
and grow your
application and learned
how to manage your CI/CD
deployments on Google Cloud.
JOLENE TEO: We also went
over logging, monitoring,
and more with Cloud Operations
for your deployed applications.
And following that, we also
went through billing, as well as
cost optimization.
And finally, for
today's episode,
which is the final episode
of the start series,
we also went through customer
care support, as well as
the support packages
available to provide you
with the integrated
care experience.
And with that, that
concludes our start series.
We're so thankful that you
joined us on this journey.
JEEVANA HEGDE: We're really
excited to share with you more
in our next segment,
the build series,
where we are going to help
startups that have already
launched on Google Cloud
to optimize and scale.
Let us know in the
comment section
below what you
thought of the series.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to our YouTube
channel, and stay tuned for
more such amazing content.
JOLENE TEO: And that's a wrap.
Thank you, and we can't wait
to see you in our next series.
JEEVANA HEGDE: Bye, for now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]